how much do you think this Advanced
operating environment is worth wait just
one minute before you answer watch as
windows integrates lotus123 with Miami
Vice now we can take this Ferrari and
paste it right into Windows right now
how much do you think Microsoft Windows
is worth don't answer wait until you see
Windows right and windows paint and to
listen to what else you get it no extra
charge the MS-DOS executive an
appointment calendar a card file a
notepad a clock a control panel a
terminal a principle or Ram driver and
can you believe it reversity that's
right all these features in reversity
all for just how much did you guess
500 a thousand even more no it's just 99
that's right it's 99 it's an incredible
value but it's true it's windows from
Microsoft order today P.O box 286 dos
except in Nebraska